el cólera está enfermando a los niños de
Haití el 40% de los casos por el brote
son de menores de edad pero expertos del
fondo de Naciones Unidas para la
infancia temen que estas cifra sea mayor
Ya que en el empobrecido país de más de
11 millones de habitantes escasean los
informes en el área de salud la cuestión
es que la desnutrición y el cólera se
retroalimentan Así que si estás
desnutrido serás más débil por lo que es
más probable que contraigas cólera y
mueras lo que también pasa es que a
veces los niños tienen cólera o diarrea
y luego se deshidratan y llegan a la
desnutrición entonces uno puede conducir
al otro y viceversa ambos son terribles
para los niños y es algo que realmente
puede matarlos y al panorama de salud se
le suma la profunda crisis política y de
seguridad de Haití con altos de
registros de desnutrición y poco acceso
a productos básicos en Haití se puede
romper el círculo vicioso entre la
desnutrición y el cólera un tratamiento
sencillo asequible y eficaz puede salvar
la vida de los niños siempre que
lleguemos a las familias más vulnerables
antes de que sea demasiado verde pero
las áreas urbanas pobres más afectadas
por el brote de cólera también están
bajo el control de bandas fuertemente
armadas en medio de la violencia armada
generalizada y la inseguridad en gran
parte de la capital los equipos
humanitarios caminan sobre cáscaras de
huevo entre las acciones conjuntas que
ha desplegado unicef se encuentran 245
kits de cólera con vitaminas y
antibióticos
135.000 pastillas potabilizadoras de
agua
468,160 litros de agua distribuidos en
camiones cisterna 300.000 sobres de
alimentos terapéuticos anuncios de
prevención del cólera por radio
televisión y folletos sin embargo el
organismo de la ONU asegura que todavía
necesita
27,5 millones de dólares para asistir a
más de 1,4 millones de personas